The goal is to tell a story
that has multiple points of view for the
very reasons that we've been discussing
and two,
by doing so indicate on an artistic
level that the old idea of the single,
even the old idea of the single author,
if you will,
is flawed
because it takes ultimately many people
to tell the story of a community or the
story of a society.
So that sense of the August author who
can come in and speak for women and
speak for men.
I don't believe that.
Well,
maybe your imagination is sufficient.
Maybe not.
You know,
my imagination comes into play.
But before doing that,
I would like to know how a man feels or
how another woman feels about something.
I'm studying that because I understand
that I'm one human being with a set of
experiences that color my lens and I've
always been since I was a little girl,
very interested in how that person
across the town across the street.
How did they think and understanding.
I could never think likely think,
but wanting to try to do something about
that gap.
Not even in a humanistic way.
It was really something that bothered
me.
It was really something I worried about.
So first of all,
I hope that by being present as 46
people say in twilight a play about the
Los Angeles riots and playing a Korean
woman who's store was burned to the
ground by African Americans or playing
one of the African American kids who
beat up a white man or playing daryl
gates,
the very unpopular a chief of police
that it suggests to an audience that
they don't have to sit in there one
position.
And by the way,
you know,
when I come out at the end and take my
curtain call,
I'm still me.
So did I really lose anything?
No fact.
Maybe I gained something.
Um,
aesthetically and artistically,
what I've been trying to contribute is
something about details that,
you know,
maybe there's a wider variety of human
beings than we've thought about and we
can tell compelling stories without
having to have those same stereotypes
that we've thinking about over and over
again.
Um,
so I've been trying to contribute
something about variety that I had hoped
and I haven't succeeded,
um,
that I hope would change the very nature
of the way theater is produced and who
comes to the theater because the theater
is a very segregated place.
Most of the people who run theaters are
in this country are white people.
My generation had many promising
directors and producers and writers and
they're not around.
They're not making theater.
And it breaks my heart and I feel in
some ways that
I haven't contributed nearly enough in
terms of what my thought about that was
when I first was studying acting in the
theater where everybody on the stage was
white and everybody in the audience was
white.
And I thought,
that's so weird.
I'm in San Francisco.
There's Asian people up the hill.
There's black people across the bay.
There's every kind of person here.
There's Latinos all over the mission.
How could this theater of this town have
everybody white on the stage?
Unless it was a black guy bringing in a
pizza,
a character,
bringing the peace and everybody in the
audience is why?
How could that be?
So I thought,
well,
what made me,
if I figured out a way to bring more
colors of people onto the stage,
more colors of people come to the
audience.
That hasn't happened.
So you know,
I think there's so much work yet to be
done in the American theater so that it
as a cultural form can help mirror the
magnificent way that this country has
changed since the time I was a girl in
Baltimore,
but I just don't feel it has and it
breaks my heart.
It breaks my heart.